alors je vous disais donc qu'il y à un
bas relief qui vont plus d'un million de
la rrq avait été volé au musée des
beaux-arts qui était retrouvé par la
sûreté du québec
reportage maxence bilodeau voici la
fameuse oeuvres qu'on retrouvait les
policiers un fragment de bas-reliefs
perse datant du 5e siècle avant
jésus-christ
les policiers l'exil fièrement un
million deux cent mille un record ça
promet fois de cette valeur c'est la
première fois on retrouve d'autres
d'autres d'autres wagons qui rompit
genre ce montant ne jamais l'histoire
commence ici au musée des beaux arts de
montréal le 3 septembre 2011 en plein
jour le musée est ouvert
un homme se dirige dans la section de
l'antiquité est ravi le bas relief qui
se trouve là exposé sans vitre comme le
sont encore aujourd'hui quelques autres
oeuvres d'art
le voleur le glisse dans un sac et saufs
sans être inquiété un mois et demi plus
tard dans la pièce d'à côté
exactement le même stratagème cette fois
une statuette de marbre de 40000 dollars
et volée à edmonton en adaptant les
policiers annoncent avoir retrouvé le
bas relief dans son logement à edmonton
ils n'ont pas encore épinglé le voleur
mais on trouver l'acheteur un albertain
de 33 ans qui savait que c'était une
oeuvre volée
pourquoi un albertain de 33 ans achètes
une oeuvre comme celle là d'après vous
je peux je vous ai que lorsqu'ils
achètent va dans le sens du tempo
qu'elle valait un coin du million ils la
paient combien je peux pas vous dire
pour l'instant mais c'est une valeur
ridicule comparativement à la valeur de
leurs noms de quelques centaines de
dollars dans les environs le voleur
court toujours mais la sûreté du québec
croit qu'un dénouement serait imminent
chose certaine le musée est très content
de retrouver son bas relief pers
c'est notre seul exemple et c'est
important parce que c'est notre seul
représentant de cet aspect de l'histoire
demeure
on ne rentre pas à la maison sans
escorte policière quand on a une valise
qui vaut un million deux cent mille
le conservateur john face et ramène le
bas relief au musée près deux ans et
demi après qu'il soit disparu dans le
sac d'un voleur ici maxence bilodeau
radio canada montréal